welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
advanced image techniques so in this
video we're going to take a look at some
fancier things that you can do with
images
i want to start off by talking about
image maps
the basic idea behind an image map is
uh suppose i want to link different
parts of an
image to different web pages and it's
kind of apropos that
maddie's gone out of right now because
she's our first example
so here's maddie facing off with the
roomba and
let's say we want to link this image to
a webpage well that's easy enough we
already know how to do that we just go
ahead and have
the image tag we should go ahead and
surround it with an a href equals and
then
wherever we want the user to go when
they click on the image they're going to
go to that location but
you know suppose we're not quite sure do
we want to go to the web page
many.html if somebody clicks on madi
versus the roomba's
photo or do we want to go to the
roomba.html webpage
it'd be nice if we could actually go to
different web pages depending on where
the user clicked on the image
so the user clicks on maddie's part of
the image we go to maddie.html and if we
click on the roomba part of the image we
go to roomba.html
and it turns out that this technique is
actually useful in
a lot of places so for example here's a
aerial photograph of stanford i got from
the stanford archives
and you can see uh you know we might
want to have different
parts of campus highlighted and if
people clicked on the different parts of
campus we would go to different
locations
based on the specific part of the
photograph they clicked on
or let's say you were part of the
organization
and you know you had a photograph where
there were a bunch of
the members of your organization all in
the photograph
and i use this particular image because
i wanted an image with a lot of people
in it
that i knew wasn't going to have a
copyright issue so this is a
us government photograph all right so uh
we've got
different people uh in this image um
we have a bunch of people everybody
knows we have uh
in the back we have our counterterrorism
expert
um we have uh i should look this up
beforehand i believe that
uh james clapper and the effort right uh
believe he was uh director of national
intelligence anyway so there's a bunch
of different people on this photograph
and if we click on the different people
in this photograph we want to go to the
different
web pages based on where we click on the
photograph
and so that's the whole idea behind
image maps and they're actually pretty
straightforward
they are somewhat specialized you know
these situations don't come up all the
time but they definitely do come up so
this is a handy
tool to have in your toolbox so we're
going to have a
simple example to start off with and so
we have a image of a computer here
and there's different parts to this
computer so suppose we're selling these
computers and we want people to be able
to go to
different locations uh different web
pages to learn about the different
components of the computer
if they click on the speakers we're
going to take them to a web page where
we talk about the speakers
if we click on the monitor we're going
to take them to a different web page
specifically about the monitor and so on
um and i i'm talking about moving the
web page
from one location to another you can
actually also do some other things you
could
trigger some javascript based on where
the user was moving their mouse as well
so this isn't strictly limited to just
creating links
all right so what we need to do here is
we need to take several steps we need to
define a map and so this is the map for
our
computer image and there's a couple
things to note so we have a map start
tag and map end tag and we've given a
name
to the map the map start tag has a name
attribute value pair and so that's going
to be important
ultimately we're going to need to know
what that name is in order to link this
map to the specific image
and then we have a whole bunch of
different areas here and
each of these areas has a shape in this
particular case they're all just
shape equals rectangle and then we have
a set of coordinates
and then we have a href equals and so
that is where we're going to take the
user the next web page we're going to
take the user if they click
inside this particular area and then
you're supposed to also have an
alt okay so let's take a closer look at
this first
area here shape rectangle coordinates 50
20 215 157 what are those
so this is to take the user to
information about the computer display
or the computer monitor
display and monitor more or less
synonymous
and so the 50 20 is actually the
coordinates of the top left-hand corner
of
the uh monitor 215 157 is actually the
bottom
right hand corner of the rectangle where
if we the user clicks within that
rectangle we want them to
go to components monitor.html
and as to where you're going to get
these coordinates most
image processing programs are going to
be able to get you these coordinates
you may need to look up uh online to
find out exactly where these coordinates
show up
as you know i'm on windows so windows
comes with a
free program called paint paint
definitely has these coordinates
available to you
certainly if you want to use something
fancy like adobe photoshop that's going
to have these coordinates for you so
you're just going to have to
load up your image into one of these
image processing
pieces of software and then actually
just move the mouse around
get the coordinates of the individual
rectangles you want to work with
okay so we've got all the different
parts of our map defined
all the different rectangles which we
want to have take the user to different
locations
we're going to go ahead and get that set
up all right the next step is
to actually associate the image map with
the
actual image and so here i've got the
img tag that i'm using to actually put
this image on the web page
and then i've got the map that we just
looked at a minute ago and so
the key points here are the img tag now
has this use map
attribute value pair and the use map
attribute value pair should have its
value
a number sign followed by the name of
the map
um we mentioned the name of the map a
minute ago well here's how you connect
the two together
so i think this technique is pretty
straightforward
uh you need to know it exists so now you
know it exists
and then you know when you have those
sort of situations where this is going
to be useful it's not too bad to work
with
now i've been showing you just
rectangles but this actually works for
non-rectangular areas as well so here
i've got a part of the cantor center for
visual arts which is stanford's art
museum
and you can see we've got that octagon
in the top left which is actually where
the thinker is
and so it's possible to define polygonal
areas as well as rectangular areas
and then we've got that little
semi-circle down in the bottom right
you can go ahead define that as a
circular area
okay so here's another technique which
can actually be extremely useful if you
have a web page
with a lot of really small images
and so this is called css sprites or css
image sprites
and the basic idea here is if you have a
lot of images on your web page it's
going to take a long time to download
remember each of those images needs to
be downloaded individually
the web browser can download several
different files simultaneously from
a web server but at some point
it's going to max out and so you can't
download 15 images simultaneously
from a web server that's not going to
happen it's going to start downloading
them sequentially and that's really
going to
slow down your web page appearance
so there's several different techniques
that you can use to get around this
the first one is css sprites and then
i'll show you another
technique in a couple minutes okay so
i've got two different web pages here
the webpage on the left is the sprites
version of the page and the
version on the right is the no sprites
version of the page otherwise
they look pretty much the same if you
look really carefully i didn't do a
great job
getting the alignment exactly right on
these items but it's certainly possible
to get all the items properly aligned on
both versions of the page
okay now here's the thing that's a
little bit fancy so it turns out the
left version of the page
only has one image for the entire web
page whereas the right version of the
web page has
four images for the web page how can
this be
well let's start off with the no sprites
version of the webpage this is the
version that you
you guys can all create at this point
and so uh you know in the body i've got
a bunch of img tags i've got four
different img tags and i've got four
different
images on the server so i've got the
caution the no
the signal and the stop and those are
all independent image files
and they all get loaded by these four
different img tags
here's what the sprites version of the
html looks like
you can see that we've got four
different divs
but i don't actually have any images at
all on
the in the html what's going on here
so as the name css sprites suggests
i'm actually going to work on the images
from the css
part of the the html file
so instead of putting the information in
the body i'm going to go ahead and put
it in the style sheet
either an internal style sheet or an
external style sheet
and so what i've got here is this is
what the web page would look like
if i turned a border on for those
four divs if you're actually doing this
for
css sprites you're not actually going to
put a board around it but i just want to
want to put
give you an idea of what's going on here
that's the space those borders are there
that's the space that i'm setting aside
for these four divs and i'm going to go
ahead and do
that by giving them a height and a width
in the in the style sheet
and then i'm going to have a single
image that i'm going to download
for this webpage and here it is
combine.gif and you can see that all
four of the
symbols that i want to appear on my web
page are all combined onto this single
gif
now what i'm going to do is in the style
sheet i'm going to go ahead and write
style rules for each of these different
divs you'll notice i gave each of the
divs
different ids and so this first
div i go ahead and give it a height and
width and then i take advantage of this
background image
style property and so what the
background image style property does is
it says
you can take any element on the web page
and you can stuff a background image
behind it and in this particular case
i'm going to stuff our combined.gif as
the background image
and it turns out if that background
image doesn't actually fit within
uh the background of the particular item
um there's there's a bunch of things
that you can kind of control and play
around with but
the basic setting here is it gets cut
off so you know that whole
image is behind our div here uh
but only the
uh traffic light's actually going to
show up i've left the rest there kind of
uh
faded out just to remind ourselves that
that's the whole that whole
combined gif is back there but only the
traffic light is actually going to
appear on the web page
and then i go ahead and do the same
thing for the next div so for
sprite 2 that's the id for our second
div
i go ahead and do the same thing but in
addition to using the background
image style property i use a second
style property associated with
background images which is the
background position i shift
that background image
over slightly so that the traffic light
is no longer showing directly behind
this div instead the stop sign is
showing behind it
and again everything's going to get cut
off except for what's actually behind
the div so you know
i'm showing that full gift there with
the traffic light
and the stop and the uh the cancel
and the caution but really the only
thing that's actually going to appear on
the web page is the part that's directly
behind this div which is a stop sign
and then of course i just do the same
thing for the other four images
and ultimately what appears on the web
page is
exactly the same thing that appeared on
the web page when
i had four different img tags so
you know again you you probably won't
see
huge savings if you have just a few
images um
i believe uh the web browsers will now
download up to five files simultaneously
i could be wrong on that but
uh it used to actually be only two files
simultaneously and they've slowly
increased the amount
but uh you know the more things that
you're trying to download from the
server the slower your web page is going
to appear
and so this is an example of a real
world sprite
this is an old sprite page for as you
can tell amazon.com
and if you were to count up each of
these little
parts of the image there's probably over
60 images here
and so if amazon needed to download
these all individually that would take a
really long time that would really kind
of bog their connection down it would
slow down
the the appearance of the web page for
their customers and they don't want that
to happen so
instead they download a single image
file
and then they use the css sprites
technique to uh
to actually put the parts of the
sprite file onto the web page
okay so previously we've seen that
we can take an image with no sprites and
have four images on the web page and we
can take
an image with sprites and have one image
on the web page i am now going to reduce
the number of
uh image files associated with the web
page to zero i'm going to simplify it
and just work with a single image
mostly because this is going to turn out
to take up a lot of space on the screen
but just
you can extrapolate from what i'm going
to show you and actually replace
all four of these images on on our
sprites and no sprites version of the
webpage
with this new technique and get
completely rid of any image files
okay so this is called base64
and the idea here is bits or bits as we
talked about the very first week of this
class
and so it turns out that you can stick
bits into your html file
um the html file is going to expect to
look like text that's okay
we can go ahead and convert an image
file to
a bunch of bits and then we can ask the
computer if these bits were
being represented as uh as text
uh what what would this appear as what
would these ascii
uh characters look like and so that's
exactly what this this technique does
so um the simplified version of the web
page with just a signal is actually
going to take
zero image files and here's what it
looks like
now we've got our img and then at the
very very bottom you can see i
close out the img tag with the alt equal
signal
and then i've got this big old source
thing what what the
what the heck is that and so that is the
actual
bits that compose the uh the signal
um and so uh i've gone ahead and
taken those bits and said hey if i were
to represent those bits as
as text uh what would they look like um
and i've gone ahead and converted those
bits
treated them as text stuck that into my
text editor
for my html file but when the web
browser gets to it
it's going to look at this and say oh i
see that this is marked as
src equals data image gif base64 and i'm
going to
re this big long text string and
actually
treat it as a bunch of bits which
ultimately i'm going to treat as
an image this technique can definitely
increase the speed at which your web
pages will
download it is a bit more work it's a
little unwilling to work with
but it's definitely out there and
something that's generally supported now
so you may be wondering if i want to use
this technique
how do i convert my image to
those text strings basically there's a
whole bunch of websites out there that
will do it for you
just google base64 image encoder
you can find different websites that
will take your image convert them to
strings and then you can just take those
strings and stick them into your html
files
okay that's it for now i'll talk to you
all soon